Martin Gordon has been living in Berlin
for 18 years becoming a committed
European along the way his country's
decision to leave the EU took him by
surprise gloom and despondency because
it's a disaster there in a bit were you
looking up and it's it's something that
I didn't really expect I must admit but
he put a back-up plan in place recently
he got a German passport as a musician
he sells his songs around the world Phil
wise also says he was certain his home
country would stay in the EU he works
for an IT company in Berlin but now he's
worried that he'll soon need a visa with
a work permit to stay it's a little bit
worrying if you're in a tech sector
which is incredibly international and
being isolated it just makes no sense
when you want your access to markets you
want it easy trade your better easily
just no move people around and it won't
just be the economy that suffers but
also fills family he wants his young son
to grow up in a Europe with open borders
Dale car has been selling British
curiosities here in Berlin for the past
20 years she's never had any problems
importing the goods over now though she
fears she'll start facing additional
costs and custom duties but mainly she's
begun to doubt her own identity so I
start to look at my little Union Jackson
kind of wonder raised is this really
nice till it's a strange thing to think
because you know I've been British my
entire life and know of a sudden I start
to question this she's even considering
becoming a German citizen Britain's
decision to distance itself from Europe
is leaving many Brits here feeling a
million miles away from their home
country